Speaker 1: I want to start today with the
Haitian immigration crisis.
This is potentially one of the first major
Joe Biden tests that is sort of going aimlessly
and contributing to Joe Biden's declining
approval rating.
We talked about Joe Biden needs a big accomplishment
to stem the decline in his approval rating.
The situation with Haitian immigrants does
not seem to be helping.
So we're going to go through it.
And I think, you know, it's there's this unfortunate
thing where every time I say, hey, guys, this
is Biden dropping the ball here, people angrily
email me and they say, David, have you become
some kind of right wing trump or whatever?
Presidents mishandle things.
And it doesn't mean that I would prefer Donald
Trump to be president of the United States.
Just sometimes presidents don't immediately
or at all handle situations correctly.
And I think this is one of those situations
where due to its complexity and due to conflicting
messaging from the current administration,
it is hurting Joe Biden.
And we can talk about to what degree that's
fair.
So let's start with some of the latest news
here.
Reuters reporting angry scenes at Haiti airport.
Add to Biden pressure over expulsions.
And we'll talk about what that means in a
second.
Angry scenes broke out at Haiti's main airport
on Tuesday among migrants sent home from a
squalid Texas border camp as U.S. President
Joe Biden faced mounting pressure to stop
an expulsions policy, the U.N. refugee refugee
chief said it may be illegal.
Nearly 10000 migrants, mainly Haitian, remain
in worsening conditions in the impromptu camp
that sprung up under a bridge spanning the
as it's called in the in the U.S., the Rio
Grand from the Texas town Del Rio to Mexico
City.
That Akuna.
In recent days, U.S. authorities have removed
at least 4000 people from the site for processing
and detention centers.
Some five hundred twenty three Haitians have
been deported to their homeland on four flights,
with repatriation set to continue on a regular
basis.
According to DHS, returnees reacted angrily
as they stepped off flights at Port au Prince
airport after spending thousands of dollars
on arduous voyages from the troubled Caribbean
nation via South America, hoping for a better
life in the United States.
On Tuesday, they found themselves back where
they started.
A group of men in white T-shirts rushed back
toward the plane after they disembarked, with
one man attempting to get back on board.
Witnesses said the migrants broke into a restricted
area of the airport as they attempted to recover
passports and personal belongings.
Ground staff close the door of the plane before
the man could scale the steps back in.
Tempers ran high, exacerbated by the news
the Haitian government had accepted the deportations.
So there's there's an OK article in Politico
outlining the potentially problematic future
of this for Joe Biden.
Now, before we look at the article, I think
it's important to mention part of the problem
here is that this is a very complicated situation.
And you simultaneously have Jen Psaki saying
the treatment of the migrants is unacceptable
and you have deportations.
But they're saying, well, the people being
deported are basically just the men, but the
women and children are staying and conservatives
are angry either way.
So I'm not pretending that there is objectively
a correct solution here that would absolve
Joe Biden of any drag on his approval.
But we can still acknowledge that this is
causing a problem for Joe Biden.
The Politico article says Biden slips into
political quicksand amid Haitian migrant buildup.
The articles by Natasha Korecki and Laura
Baron Lopez.
And the article says the mass of thousands
of Haitians at the U.S. southern border has
put the Biden administration in the exact
place it's tried to avoid knee deep in immigration
politics.
I think that's completely accurate.
In the past 24 hours, the White House has
responded to images and videos of aggressive
tactics used by Border Patrol to corral migrants
by supporting an internal investigation into
the matter.
What it hasn't done yet is figure out a solution
to the crowding and sanitary issues arising
in what's become a makeshift encampment or
stop its policy of deporting migrants upon
arrival.
That's left the president and his team with
few supporters and allies.
And we can talk about what should be done.
While also recognizing that in terms of Biden
taking heat, there's almost really nothing
he could do right.
You criticized the treatment of the migrants
by Border Patrol and the right says, oh, look,
you're on the side of the illegals rather
than have law enforcement and then you do
deportations.
And the left says, well, but if we're acknowledging
that these people aren't being treated correctly,
then you just send them out back to the situation
that is a disaster in their country.
Now, that's also bad and that's inhumane.
And you don't improve the situation at the
encampment and that's inhumane.
But if you do improve it, then the right says
you're coddling criminals as they like to
say.
So I get that no matter what, there would
be criticism.
And yet we can still talk about what is the
correct path forward, which we which we will
do.
The article in Politico goes on to say, A
coalition of more than thirty eight civil
rights and immigrant advocacy leaders sent
the White House a letter calling on Biden
to stop expulsions, some of whom arrived to
the border community after fleeing violent
and natural violence and natural disaster
in their home country.
The letter marks a final straw, said Nana
Gaddafi, executive director of the Black Alliance
for Just Immigration, described the moment
as an inflection point for Biden's commitment
to a humane immigration policy.
Members of the president's own party, including
Chuck Chuck Schumer, echoed the call to end
expulsions.
Increasingly, they did so while directing
their ire at the White House for its handling
of the situation.
Twelve House Dems will hold a press conference
calling on Biden to halt deportations.
So what is it that should be done here?
It's not totally clear, but it's causing a
problem for Joe Biden, whose approval rating
has now hit a new low of 43 percent as of
yesterday, Kamala Harris down to 49 percent.
This is the lowest approval rating that Joe
Biden has had.
And this does not yet fully account for what's
going on at the border with the Haitian migrants.
This poll ended on September 17th, and it
has Joe Biden down to a presidency low of
43 percent.
Now, it is typical that presidents see approval
decline throughout their presidency.
As we've talked about before, many people,
just as soon as the president does one thing
they don't like, they say I no longer approve.
And it's often difficult to change that.
We've seen that with many presidents.
At the same time, there is a question here
about whether Joe Biden drops into the 30s.
And my expectation my prediction was, as we
saw the approval ratings start to go down
around the Afghanistan situation, which I
agree with, leaving Afghanistan is just as
a reminder, if you've not seen those segments,
my thought was it'll get down into the low
40s before it might turn around and start
going up.
I don't think the situation in Del Rio is
going to help.
So what should happen?
You know, it seems as though a sort of balanced
approach here would be provide better conditions
and sanitation, figure out a way to do it.
The right will say you're being soft.
But remember, the right's been saying that
since January 22nd, before Joe Biden changed
anything about what was being done at the
border, the right was already saying Joe Biden
is being soft.
So either way, they're going to say that materially
improve the sanitation situation at the border
must do there's food shortages, et cetera.
Do some kind of a temporary pause on the expulsions.
Now, the right will say these people are here
illegally.
So, of course, you're going to deport them.
And at a certain point, this is going to have
to be adjudicated in a more serious way.
But the problem is, if you don't put a pause
here, you don't even allow the opportunity
to say, is there a valid case for asylum here?
Now, many of us would say, obviously there
is.
Look at the situation in Haiti.
It's a legal question.
But if you just immediately do the expulsions,
you don't even allow the opportunity to do
that.
You're not going to please the right.
That's the reality.
But at this point, nobody's happy with how
this is being handled.
And I think the major criticism is it seems
aimless, where it's not really clear what
is even the goal down there.
And so we will see if in the I think by Monday
there has to be some clear messaging and we
may even get it today from Jen Psaki, who's
going to be by the time you listen or watch
today, the press briefing will likely already
have been held.